[Music]
okay so this is my review
of episode one of the new showtime
series your honor
this episode is directed by edward
berger and written by peter moffat
this show is actually an adaptation of a
israeli series
kuvodu and now it's being americanized
and what drew me in to cover this show
is of course the leading man here brian
cranston who's actually
the leading role in the tv show for the
first time
since breaking bad ended in 2013. so i'm
sure it's a big reason why a lot of
people are viewing this show
as well and giving it a shot so this
show takes place in new orleans
and it's a story about this judge
michael and his son
adam now even in the first scene with
adam and his girlfriend i always find it
silly that they have to show us
two naked butts right away i don't
really see the point i don't think
anyone's really asking for that
so that's the foot the show starts on
visually but
the important story here starting up is
that this
takes place on the anniversary of the
death of adam's mother
and on a re-watch of this episode you'll
catch a lot of things that are really
important that will definitely
be something that comes back to haunt
adam and his father
in court one thing i caught was that the
neighbor is this lady that sits on a
porch outside
basically all day she saw adam leave
that day
and she also saw when he came back all
bloody and they make a big point of this
especially because one of the shots they
open with her just eating peanuts they
wouldn't just show this random way to
eating peanuts on the porch if it wasn't
important
and what was interesting about leading
up to this big moment where he hits the
kid on the motorcycle
i just felt like you knew the minute
that kid got that motorcycle as a gift
he was a goner and that's how he was
gonna die so i was kind of just waiting
for that motorcycle to appear when adam
was driving around town but what they're
cutting back and forth between
is actually in the beginning showing
michael his dad
played by brian cranston on his run he
even stops at his wife's grave
but he makes a stop at this house
in this poor neighborhood and it's
actually the house that has directly to
do with the case
he is handling as a judge and this is
just to show you how honorable of a
judge
he is looking for the truth in all ways
and it's completely just to go
that far to check on that case but
before we get back to michael
we see with adam that he's asthmatic
which is super important
and is really a big variable in all
these events that take place so
where stuff starts at the fan with adam
as he brings his mother's photo to this
yaya's food store in this bad
neighborhood clearly the spot his mother
died but
you see there's like this gang that
comes up to him and he wants to get out
of there he starts panicking his asthma
starts kicking up
but what's even crazier is there's a car
following him so that's what's causing
him to drive really fast and not focus
clearly and eventually into him hitting
in this motorcycle
and he can't reach his inhaler but
that's a little another thing you got to
pay attention to is that
when he hits this motorcycle the car
that was following him was still there
sees what happened completely but turns
around and leaves a scene that's also
going to be very important who was in
that car what was the eyewitness
the most frustrating thing about this
character in adam is that the minute he
hit the kid
on the motorcycle he doesn't first go
and grab his inhaler in the car
he first goes and checks on the kid and
this is just so
frustrating to watch because he's having
this asthma attack but also panicking so
that when he actually
uses the kid's phone to call the police
he doesn't just open his mouth and tell
them what happened
so you could tell yeah he's in shock but
you find yourself screaming at the
screen at this kid but again more little
important things like
the kid who was hit his dad's calling
him on the phone at that moment right
before adam actually makes a call to the
police and that also that adam attempted
cpr
on the kid which is definitely gonna
leave dna all over
his mouth which will be important but
this little detail you gotta catch which
will come back later around which will
also make you so frustrated that adam is
that
when he decides in the reverse order now
which wasn't smart to actually go grab
his inhaler to
stop his asthma attack at the car he
decides when he's laying against the car
just drop his inhaler which is so dumb
leaves it right on the ground
for them to find later on at the end of
the episode which we'll get to and where
he
really screwed up because he had a
couple chances here to redeem himself
was when he actually was coming down a
bit from his panic attack
and his asthma attack the police were
still on the phone he had every chance
to still just say
what happened and he decides not to just
dumb you might as well stay at that
point telling what happened especially
because you know you just gave the kid
mouth to mouth and put your dna all over
the scene
and adding to like i said when he came
home after this happened and the
porch lady eating peanuts saw him he
also stopped before that
at the gas station and they show you
that he's on the camera so these are all
things just going against his
favor so now let's go back to michael i
love when they show him as a judge
when the defense lawyer comes in he says
he's late because he has prostate cancer
and he has to pee every 15 minutes
this got huge payoff because michael
would end up using this on the bridge
when the cop sees him
and says the reason he's there is
because he has to pee and he has
prostate cancer
so nice writing there making everything
count here and half purpose
and just to pay off the setup of
michael's character and what we know
about him being this honest
judge is that he calls out this crooked
cop for trying to just
get this person put to jail on a lie and
he even says
you might be a liar of the vilest kind
so
this to me seems like if we're going
from
pole to pole character writing which
we've seen with ryan cranston before
obviously i'm breaking bad he's this
honest judge here
but i have a feeling obviously that line
is foreshadowing that he's going to
become
the vilest liar by the end of this show
is brian cranston breaking bad again we
will see
also quick little important scenes is
that when he's leaving
the court we meet this guy who's running
for mayor who's gonna be this powerful
person that michael knows and he says
michael saved his life so this is gonna
be a powerful figure that
michael clearly knows owes him a favor
and will probably help his side
michael's gonna have to play all these
cards and connections he has to protect
his son as we go forward in this show so
they're kind of laying the seeds for
that
and just to add to the frustration of
adam he doesn't know how to use a
wash machine properly it's just
ridiculous i always feel like i have
that bias when you see
a younger kid character in a show and
they're just being stupid you just
want to scream the whole time and then
daddy has to come home and mop up his
mess with all the bloody clothes later
on but there's a really good scene here
when the sun lets
michael know what exactly happened and
you get important lines from michael's
character like i love you more than
anything in this world again
his motivation what will make him become
this liar to protect his son at all
costs and it's interesting because with
michael's character
when he's getting the story from adam
he's already finding ways to justify it
any way possible really
honing in on the shock factor that adam
was in saying oh yeah you were in total
shock though right
and you could even see in adam's face
played
really well by the actor that he feels
guilty still and
he knows he probably could have still
done this better it's not totally
justifiable even though he was having a
panic attack
even though he was having an asthma
attack there were still moments he could
have redeemed himself and he left the
scene
and left someone to die as he says but
the dad doesn't want to hear that the
dad wants to
justify this in his head to protect his
son even going to the extremes comparing
it to when his mother died and that
that put him in shock so i was like yeah
this is part of who you are so clearly
they're going to use that as the case to
defend him but they both get to their
senses here and the right move is to go
to the police station
and it's important to remember michael
put in this call to the police station
first that they were coming so that's
going to be held against him as well but
we get this big twist
that the father of the boy on the
motorcycle is
this crime boss jimmy baxter played by
michael
stuhlbarg so this stops really all
of michael's plan here he knows this is
worse than he could have imagined
because
it's not now just going to be a case of
making sure his son doesn't go to prison
and they can get out of this
and he can use his connects now it's him
versus basically this mob and that
he knows if they ever find out his son
did this he's gonna get
whacked and that's why he panics and
he's like no we gotta go and he's like i
can keep you safe if no one hears about
this so you see how quickly
his character is turning now at all
costs to defend his son but man
you just see that dog just grab the
bloody rag here when michael's cleaning
up the clothes
and the car brutal that's gonna haunt
them and like how the episode ends
it's gonna haunt them about the inhaler
that adam stupidly left
on the street so what's interesting
about this show
i didn't think it was the most thrilling
premiere i don't think it was the most
hooking either but i think
it was entertaining enough and had some
really good character writing
and had a twist and it has you intrigued
so i think it deserves an 8.6
also for great acting i still love the
color palette that is used a lot in
crime dramas like this the cold blues
here just really sets
the mood well and how we're going to see
this man change now
it's hard for me to predict where this
show show's gonna go i think it has so
much upside and so much downside i think
the upside here is clearly with brian
cranston
especially it's exciting to see him do a
lead role in the tv show again we
haven't seen that since breaking bad and
i think
most interesting part of the story is
gonna be how his character changes and
who he becomes and
the decisions he'll make however i think
the downside is keeping it interesting
over 10 episodes because we already know
exactly what happened
the day of the motorcycle accident we
saw it with our own eyes
so how much will keep us invested and
hooked there's not
really much mystery here so it's is it
just going to be this war between
michael and jimmy baxter how well will
this hold up for 10 episodes will it
drag on
or will there be more twists and things
we didn't know maybe prior that happened
with the mother's death and maybe they
can go more into detail maybe
we'll end up learning that jimmy baxter
was somehow responsible for their
mother's death who knows so
hopefully they make it more complicated
and interesting because i'm just a
little afraid that knowing
exactly what happened with the
motorcycle accident how much will keep
people invested and hooked because it's
great to have great character
storytelling but we need a little more
than that too so we'll see where this
goes
but again i think this is a really solid
premiere 8.6 for me
let me know down below what you thought
of this premiere i'd love to hear your
thoughts i read every comment and try to
respond as many as i can please make
sure to subscribe so you don't miss one
of my reviews of your honor i'll be
doing every episode i also do other tv
shows and movies as well and if you love
what i do here i would
really really appreciate a two dollar
monthly donation you can sign up for
there's a paypal link in the description
down below
this will help me do more videos for you
guys that will make sure i can do this
full-time and get you
a bunch of videos out a week and cover
as many shows as possible so
if you like what i do that would be the
best way you can support my channel i'd
be forever
grateful and please follow me at steve
barley show on twitter instagram for
more of me
and i'll see you next time